hey everybody it is another night of
fortunately mostly peaceful protests
around the United States we're going to
be checking in on a number of different
cities and urban areas I have videos to
play for you I want to get your
questions we are going to we're gonna do
a lot of different things I have some
notes as always I come prepared with
different elements that I want to
discuss I see people
before starting who in the chat were
inquiring about the urban garden I do
have updates about that and I will get
to that momentarily
maybe we'll discuss the defunding police
movement I guess that's going on I just
I don't know that I'll talk that much
about the upgraded charges on Derek
shavon only because I believe a video
just published about that on my youtube
channel it did yeah so I don't want to
be like doing a live stream with the
exact same content that that is on the
YouTube channel right now so maybe we
won't do that right away but I'm always
glad to take suggestions and to see what
the people want for sure okay there's a
few super chats that have already come
in and they're not visible on this
screen but one of them is visible here
the first one is from comrade Matthias
who says have you been to or do you plan
to be at a protest assuming you mean
these protests I have not been to them I
listen I don't know that I can do too
much at the protest versus being here
with you guys and streaming the
different protests and also coronavirus
right I mean I don't know that I need to
be one more person there possibly
catching or spreading the virus so I've
been to many protests in my day but not
over the last five days and as of right
now I I don't plan to go Matt Chavez
says who are the unidentified people
guarding in Washington DC yeah I tweeted
about that so I can actually show you a
picture of exactly what that looks like
these folks the reports are that there
would the federal government these are
people
in sort of like generic military you
type uniforms and no name tags as they
often have and people asking them who
they're with as Dan Friedman says they
said they're with the federal government
my understanding is that there were the
Bureau of Prisons and they are officers
specifically trained in dealing with
riots at prisons and that they have been
deployed to Washington DC that's what I
know so far
thanks to Micah Galvin who says thanks
for the great content I appreciate your
thoughtful perspective interviews and
analysis keep up the good work let me
actually clean up whoa
super jets chats just went crazy I just
want to clean this up a little bit that
looks about right I would say there we
go okay good
yeah so that's that's that Bureau of
Prisons people now by the way just while
we're here can anybody explain to me
like what is the justification for what
we see what okay that doesn't seem to be
the video I wanted this is the one what
possible justification could there be
for what we see here the way police are
going after this women right door and
then ultimately this woman here on the
left like what what could have imagined
that this is quote out of context and
that like five seconds before the video
started anything you can imagine took
place that would justify this behavior
what could that something be like what
could possibly justify what what police
are doing to this woman right here I
mean okay she tried to sort of break
free she resisted in some way there's a
there's cops all around her and they're
taking turns swinging at her with batons
right like what on earth could possibly
justify this I don't know like send me a
super chatter or let me know on twitch
what what what would pop what could have
happened here that justifies this
behavior it doesn't make sense to me I
just failed to understand it okay thank
you two crazy Hawaiian in Pennsylvania
for the twitch Prime subscription who
says it's my six-month anniversary thank
you apple pie rates and Sahira have
signed up we are indeed
this is the woke stream twitch.tv/eds
have subsequent elements of the stream
this is Atlanta we will be checking in
there this is a combination of Nashville
Tennessee Detroit Michigan in the
lower-left Indianapolis Indiana and the
lower-right and here we have Seattle
Washington I can actually hear the
helicopters here in Boston as we speak
there has been there have been a couple
of actually protests today vigils some
are called gatherings others were called
and everything peaceful as far as I know
so far which is very very important and
and again remember Trump is trying to
make us think that there is widespread
violence and looting going on but we
overwhelmingly have protesters and what
they do is protest and then you have
people with nefarious motives who are
not protesters they're looters or
they're insiders or they are you know
whatever and it's important not to allow
that to be conflated insane Lane says
hello have you had the time to look into
the theater the story of the Australian
journalist attacked by police in the
follow yeah I saw the footage and I read
about it I don't have any particular
insight into it but I did I did check it
out after people recommended it last
stream also comrade Matthias says do you
think there's a limit that even Barre
won't be willing to cross also what are
the chances of barre turning against
Trump
anybody could always turn against Trump
that's always a possibility I I think
that the limit for Barr is I don't
believe Donald Trump is going to go
peacefully if he loses in November in
the sense that I believe Trump will say
it was rigged it was it was stolen in
some way because remember he's been
arguing that an election that he won was
rigged in 2016 Trump won electoral in
2016 and he spent three-and-a-half years
arguing that the results were bogus and
that it was rigged just imagine if he
loses and oh so here's the other thing I
have prepared for you guys today if
people want I will actually go through
the map and tell you why Trump is
panicking now that doesn't mean that
he's going to lose
but if people are interested I've been
studying various elements of geography
and I would be ready to present to you
essentially why Trump should be
panicking the way he is unless things
were to radically change it looks like
some people are interested in the map
some people are not ok there's a
moderate level of interest ok very good
so that I guess means maybe I'll do it
maybe I won't okay let's see who else
sent in messages Adrian Beto see Tomas
sends a super chat Adrian benningfield
says David I know there's a lot going on
but could you please cover the
immigrants being detained at the border
please I don't know I mean I they're
always immigrants being detained at the
border I don't know specifically what
you're referring to but I'll check it
out
thank you for see Tomas for subscribing
on YouTube and Byron Tobin for the super
chat che nurse says I asked a Republican
family member of police shooting
paintballs at people on their private
property was okay they should have
listened and gone inside unbelievable
yeah you know I actually just tweeted
and and people may this may resonate
with some folks I just tweeted and this
would be a beautiful oh wow I just
tweeted at ten minutes ago and it has
300 likes I said if Trump deploys the
military against protesters would that
qualify as the government tyranny that
the gun people say they will fight
against with their guns and of course
you know one of the primary
justifications that we hear from a large
swath of Second Amendment people is the
government could become tyrannical and
if it did we would need our rifles and
our handguns to fight against them so
two-part question does this count when
Trump says I don't care what governors
say I might just decide to send in the
federal military does that count as
government tyranny number two are you
gonna do anything about it and then of
course number three will your rifles and
handguns work against helicopters and
armored vehicles etc I'm just asking the
questions and I mean that quite quite
literally my friends thank you to norv
II for the support over on Twitch I am
going to
some point in this stream you know I
feel kind of bad that some of the people
that watch on Twitch have been a little
sad they've been a little sad they feel
as though we need some exclusive twitch
streams so at some point in this stream
we are going to go over exclusively to
twitch just to re sort of reassure
everybody and reprove my devotion to the
twitch audience so we will at some point
we will pinch off all of the other
streams that are going on and we will be
exclusively on twitch and at that point
it's really going to get crazy I'm gonna
talk to you about my strawberry plant
once we do that and I expect that it
could actually cause even more civil
unrest than than we've seen so far okay
ken Clive says just arrived on stream
someone may have already asked aren't
curfews against peaceful protests
unconstitutional it's unclear to me I
asked a couple lawyers about that today
and they said that there it's a
contested issue whether a curfew at all
is constitutional and in particular if
you can show that it is designed or
geared specifically towards suppressing
peace peaceful protests is it even
potentially a First Amendment violation
you know I'm not a legal scholar the
legal scholars told me that it is much
debated much debated and there is not a
definitive answer one way or the other
on that okay a couple of other things
that I wanted to show you as we are
looking at different things here here is
white house spokesman Hogan Gidley
if you can imagine a more I guess what I
mean is Hogan giddily
is the perfect name for this individual
I think is what I'm getting at Hogan
Gidley
here's Hogan giddily on the possibility
of Trump using the military to stop
protests now understand this is the next
level it was already dubious to send in
military at all when governor's have not
asked for it you've got to suspend the
posse comment
- sacked with the insurrection Act of
1807 you know we've already heard the
analysis but it was supposedly to quell
the tiny percentage of people that are
that are not peaceful protesters now the
question is what about just using it to
stop protests altogether let's take a
listen then after he left that statement
went on to the White House Hogan first
of all let me make the point that it's
the president's decision alone whether
or not to invoke the insurrection act he
was elected he was voted on by the
American people to be in the office well
he was really voted on by the Electoral
College the American people voted for
Hillary by 3 million more votes of the
presidency will be in the Oval Office he
alone makes these decisions I'm not
going to get into a private conversation
between the president the United States
and the Secretary of Defense
but I can tell you is that the president
wants all options on the table to
protect the American people and what
we've seen systematically across this
country is in a lot of places police are
not given the authority to arrest people
who are breaking the law American the
problem is the police don't have enough
power the can you imagine the police
with riot squads that have been doing
for example hold on a second where was
this the people that the police that
have been doing this stuff we've got to
empower the
right they don't have enough power okay
anyway here's Hogan good citizens are
not being protected and so the president
made the point that all options are on
the table because it's up to the federal
government to protect the people when
it's not wait a second hold on a second
let me think about that
so coronavirus starts coming in Trump
does nothing doesn't build a testing
program testing is a miserable failure
and Trump says you know where the
governor's it's up to the governor's to
get PPE it's up to the governor's to get
ventilators it's up to the governor's to
develop testing now though Hogan giddily
says the federal government ultimately
is responsible for defending the
American people really what about on
coronavirus Hogan I'd love to hear from
you about that not overreaching wildly
it is supposed to be focused singularly
on protecting the lives of the American
citizenry and that's what's important
here and that's what the president's
focused on so is it still an option for
the president all options are on the
table with this president when the lives
of the American people are at risk there
you go so I think we all know kind of
the the direction that that is is
potentially gonna it is literal garbage
I see people in the chat calling this
garbage and it is exactly garbage that
is exactly how I would describe it a
couple of other super chats coming in
let me see here Harvey willing says is
the u.s. a police state in your opinion
keep up the great work
no the u.s. is not a police state but we
are starting to see characteristics
localized in certain areas you know when
police don't let peaceful protesters
leave so that then when the curfew hits
they immediately start arresting them
like that's not you look at the ACL
u--'s protesting guides that's not how
it's supposed to work it so we are
starting to see police state
characteristics in some areas I would
not characterize a big picture the u.s.
as a police state at this point in time
and that could change mica Gelfand says
Hogan Gidley is not a real name he's
obviously not human-alien Trump ba
McClain racing says why do you think
people like Joe Rogan and cigar and
jetty completely dismiss all the videos
of police using violent
against peaceful protesters I have no
idea I didn't know that if if they've
done that I've not seen it I just don't
I just don't know what you're referring
to it's been a busy week I've not really
watched anything David D'Arcy says hi
David goony rayon bow hurl at is how you
pronounce the Irish phrase I sent you
the other night it means good luck on
your road Ireland feels genuine sympathy
for Forrest Trump's fascism all right
StuH never says they got the guns we got
the numbers unite vote hot mustard gas
says I don't know if my previous super
chat came through why is Trump tweeting
about churches burning I didn't see that
let's take a look I happen to have
Trump's tweets right here
churches burning let's see here
churches burning I'm gonna talk about
defund the police in a second churches
burning I'm not seeing that I guess
we're maybe getting to it here no you
don't burn churches in America I didn't
know any church was burned
does anybody know has any Church been
burned I know about control-f guys it's
more fun to scroll through it I don't
know a thing about churches being burned
if anybody knows about that let me know
but it's certainly something I'm
unfamiliar with at this point in time a
Michael Bay atheist amicable atheist
says David could you please talk about
the Secretary of the Army's open letter
to the service specifically the Army's
official position to protect the rights
of Americans I didn't see that I did
cover former Secretary of State Jim
mattis's brutal scathing letter but I
did not see that letter I will look into
it
and Robert Mifflin asks do you think
Esper is out definitely go over the map
okay I think that it is it is quite
plausible that mark a spurred Trump's
current Secretary of Defense will be
fired he has made it clear that listen
in a way that is not straight up saying
Trump's out of his mind
Esper has made it clear that he's not
into deploying troops in the ways that
Donald Trump wants to and I would I
would not at all be shocked if Mark
Esper were to were to get fired okay let
me get
a couple of different things indulge me
for a moment and oh I see people am I
going to be doing new member thank-yous
yes I will so let do one just to kick us
off and then I'll get caught up Eric
Kazi is new member number one today on
my website oh boy everything going wrong
over here hold on a second number one
well but there we go number one okay yes
I will be doing new member thank-yous I
always appreciate folks signing up and
everybody will get a thank you but I've
got so much content to get through that
I'm going to get back to that
momentarily number one how is my garden
doing you know there are much more
important things right now but people
are asking about about it my garden is
doing really really well I had so many
cucumber plants I threw down like 20
seeds and they all germinated that I
needed to call them because you really
supposed to have like 12 inches between
cukes
so I started pulling some of them out
gave some of them to my neighbor I've
got yellow zucchini going I've got
tomato plants are explosively growing
it's completely out of control my mint
is I've never seen mint like this before
and I have a strawberry plant this is
unbelievable with one strawberry right
now so it's slowly turning red and
ripening this is the first year for this
strawberry plant some people told me I
won't get any good strawberries till
next year I might as well just pinch the
the flowers and just let the plant grow
rather than generate strawberries but my
plan is at some point I'm gonna do a
video maybe it'll even be live where I
will go out and pick the one strawberry
it should be ripe in like a week and
then I will pick a mint leaf and I will
bring it into my house and I will put
them on a plate and with a fork and
knife I will eat the strawberry with
little pieces of mint on it and I think
it would make for pretty pretty
compelling video and it could it could
get it could get more attention than
when one of those Kardashians turned out
to have lied about being a billionaire I
think it could be huge and it would be a
sort of performance art I feel like it
would be like avant-garde performance
art to eat one single strawberry with
one leaf of mint with with with a fork
and an extremely sharp knife and in fact
I think it would be funnier visually
with like a gigantic
chef's knife so that's my idea with my
one strawberry so I'm gonna do that at
some point number two how do I feel
about defund the police okay here's my
thought about defund the police defund
the police as an umbrella idea I don't
think is that thoughtful of an idea
there's no question that we need to
demilitarize police departments
particularly in a lot of big cities now
do you do that by taking money away
maybe right so if you can surgically
reduce funding to demilitarize the
militarized police that's great I think
that that's fantastic the problem is
there's other police departments where
they don't have enough money and when
you are short-staffed what you do as a
police department is you go you do the
easy stuff you go after the low-hanging
fruit and it often leads to the type of
policing that we're trying to stop so
defunding already underfunded
departments that are having to resort to
you know cheap policing tactics that we
want to stop seems like the wrong way to
go so for me it's demilitarized the
police also I have a segment coming up
on this Friday I mentioned this on the
Tuesday stream so I don't want to take
up too much time with this but we have
to change police training police
training should be much longer like it
is in a lot of European countries and a
huge portion of it should be social work
type training because when police
officers have social work type training
they're able to de-escalate so many
situations that now are leading to
tasers are leading to physical
confrontations etc so you know and in
some cases you will need to fund that
training so this is why blanket defund
police the way I think about things it's
too simplistic and it doesn't actually
get it a lot of the issues we should
have mental health and social work type
training for police that might cost more
in the short term but we will benefit
dramatically over the long term so
that's that
that's my sense there from the
standpoint of funding of police okay let
me do a couple of Super chats and then
and thank you to Daniel 84 little blue
doggy and rinoa all of whom are
supporting now on twitch I'm gonna do
the electoral map momentarily I think
you guys will find this interesting
we're monitoring protests overwhelmingly
peaceful I would say from what we've
seen so far exclusively peaceful in
Denver
Austin Seattle Washington DC Columbus
Ohio another one in Seattle Chicago
Illinois and Atlanta we've also been
keeping an eye on a different part of
Atlanta
almost nothing is moving here it just
seems like things are basically
nothing's happening we have here oh this
dream may have died how sad would that
be if this dream died okay we have an ad
there
this is video in Seattle Washington a
very very large crowd and then here we
have video from Los Angeles in the low
right and Minneapolis Minnesota in the
upper left so we'll continue monitoring
all of these streams and seeing what is
going on okay a couple of other super
chats here let me see do you think okay
I called iCloud onyx says do you think
the violence violence against protester
he is threat threading with is a tactic
to distract from kovat 19 and blame the
protesters if there's super spreading
going on afterwards I don't think it's a
calculated strategy but I would not be
surprised to see Trump blame the growing
numbers on the protests now just briefly
let's look at some of the numbers lately
because what we've seen is that Verret
will look at yesterday's numbers when
you look at new cases California
continues to have a really big problem
but look at some of the places that now
have the most new cases in terms of
percentage texas and florida new york
still has a lot but in a percentage
growth rate it's tiny because look at
how many you know New York was an
epicenter
so California and you
or car problematic but you've got Texas
Florida Georgia Virginia Illinois and
Maryland were early spots North Carolina
New Jersey was an early spot so yeah the
reason it's relevant to mention that
they were early spots is what matters is
the the growth rate of cases all of
these places California New York
Illinois Maryland and New Jersey and
Pennsylvania they were early hot spots
so even though the raw numbers are still
high they're very much on the decline
these other places are the ones that
opened relatively early and now
irregularly I mean Texas with 1769
yesterday let's look at their curve a
lot of a lot of towns yes so Texas has
been on a slow growth path that has
lasted March April May you know two and
a half for two and a half months cases
are just slowly growing in Texas that's
a dramatically different curve then not
to brag but sorry hold on that's
California not to brag but that's a
dramatically different curve than what
we have here in Massachusetts as you can
see this one-day thing is an artifact
because they added to the total case
numbers presumptive cases so there
weren't really 3,800 cases these are
presumptive cases from all along this is
a dramatically different curve than what
Texas is seeing so in any case the point
is yes of course Donald Trump is going
to blame the protesters as cases
continue to spike in some places
Memorial Day as people are pointing out
may also be a factor there okay azeema
Abu Khalil my friend azim who's been on
the streams for a long time David do you
believe as I do that American society is
trapped in a cyclone of ignorance and
degradation of policies apologies for
the cynicism yeah I do I do
we have people running here in Atlanta
and I'm not completely sure what is
going on but it seems as though the
level of chaos is escalating marginally
there and I don't know if Lana still has
a 9:00 p.m. protest that we have hit now
10 minutes past on the East Coast but
things seem to be tough people running
you don't usually see adults running at
full speed out on the street like that's
a sign usually that's something on you
has happened so hopefully things are
still remaining calm but again each day
just overwhelmingly peaceful protests
where you know people walking together
people chanting people singing etc etc
and that is all excellent to see
excellent to see knowledge gizmo says us
is a surveillance state protesters are
watched yes that is absolutely true
Paula Faust checking in Austin Shenzi
ellos getting a membership hero she
loves you says her oh she would eat up
all of your strawberries well I only
have one right now so there aren't that
many that many strawberries to eat okay
I'm going to step away briefly from the
protests because I did want to go over
some elements of geography with you guys
and look at the map so here's what I I
want to explain so this is the way the
election went let's see if we can get a
little zoom for everybody can we zoom
this so that it looks proper oh but then
now we're not going to see the total
numbers let's keep the zoom level here I
think that this is probably appropriate
for our purposes so where to start this
is how the election went in 2016 and
there were some notable components here
first of all both Ohio and Florida were
won by Donald Trump in 2016 Republicans
often depend on Ohio and Florida to win
elections
whereas Democrats often are able to win
elections without those states so as an
example if we take some of these states
that Democrats often win and flip them
blue so for example Wisconsin Michigan
and Pennsylvania you see how without
Ohio and without Florida Hillary Clinton
would have won in 2016 we'll put these
three back the way they were which were
for Donald Trump so here's why the Trump
administration is now panicking I'm
going from memory so I you know I'm
gonna give you an estimate here of the
way this is all going down right now Joe
Biden is up by one
ohayo if I recall correctly Trump won
Ohio by 8 in 2016 so let's just imagine
that Trump loses Ohio and Joe Biden gets
that this means that if Trump simply
loses Florida it's over it he can get
Arizona which he's currently losing he
can get Wisconsin which he's currently
losing he can get Michigan which he's
currently losing and he can get
Pennsylvania which he's currently losing
if he loses Ohio only Florida flippin
where where Biden is now plus three and
a half gives this election to Donald
Trump now let's flip Florida back if
Trump loses Ohio but retains Florida Joe
Biden only needs to flip two of these
four states that he's currently leading
he could get Arizona and Wisconsin that
gets him to 271 you need to 70 by the
way he could get Arizona and Michigan
and that would get him to 270 he could
get Arizona and Pennsylvania and that
gets him to 270 he could just get you
know pick any other to Wisconsin and
Michigan and that gets him to 270 he
could get Pennsylvania alone and it gets
him to 270 so this is why the map for
Trump is he's been yelling at his
campaign manager and he can't believe
that he's losing to Joe Biden in a lot
of these states because again let's
reset the map to the 2016 actual if
Trump were to lose Ohio he essentially
can lose almost nothing else like okay
if he loses Ohio in Arizona he still
wins if he loses Ohio and Wisconsin he
still wins if he loses Ohio and Michigan
he still wins but if he loses
Pennsylvania or any two of these four
states and remember he's losing every
single one of these right now it's over
four for four Donald Trump which is why
this is so important that's really the
gist of the mapping that I wanted to go
over with you guys of interesting so
Florida alone
not do it for Joe Biden but it is
important to keep in mind that you know
in looking at these two important states
Ohio and Florida let's assume Trump
keeps Ohio but loses Florida it then
becomes very difficult because Donald
Trump has to run the table in all four
of these key states Arizona Wisconsin
Michigan and Pennsylvania if indeed
Trump loses Florida you have to assume
one of these goes for Biden Arizona
would do it
Wisconsin would put him at 271 Michigan
would put him at 277 and Pennsylvania
would put him at 281 this is why Trump
is panicking okay and when you look at
the recent polls in fact let's just do
that just to be thorough let's see here
on Real Clear Politics we'll just look
at a sampling of the recent state polls
let's see general election so floored
you know Biden plus three if Trump loses
Florida it gets very difficult in this
Pennsylvania poll Trump is still winning
that's not the case in all of them
Michigan Biden is up Wisconsin currently
a tie but then another even a Fox News
poll has Biden plus nine in Wisconsin
Arizona
you know Trump plus one but then Biden
plus four so the point is the margin of
error is very very small for Donald
Trump when it comes to the map and the
way that it's looking for for 2020 and
that is that that's essentially the
point that that I wanted to make oh
people are saying look at Texas
something interesting let me I do want
to look at let's look at what's going on
in Texas Texas Trump versus Biden Wow
Trump plus two point two and by okay so
PPP is a left-leaning poll Biden's
winning that one but even tied in the
Dallas Morning News
I am shocked so in 2016 this is
important in 2016 Trump won by nine in
2012 Romney won by 16 in 2008 McCain won
by 12 yeah I mean listen if Trump wins
Texas but only by two it's it's over I
mean there's just not even a chance now
I want to be really careful I have no
confidence that this will hold through
November I have no confidence that this
will hold through November no person
should stay home
in November because of anything we have
just looked at this is a survey of where
we are right now we're in the middle of
you know 25% of the labor force having
lost their jobs in the last 12 weeks
we're in the middle of a you know global
pandemic which Trump has failed to
respond to things can change very very
dramatically and period and every single
person of course of course of course
needs to be voting okay
other super chats that are coming in
let's take a look
Kevin Dunham says Michigan Senate passes
bill requiring implicit bias
de-escalation police training amid
national unrest and mental health
screening that's good news
Sam Dean says black lives matter protest
in Melbourne tomorrow I'll update you
Thank You el McVicker says how the
protesters have been handled in the last
week would be more than enough
justification for the u.s. to topple a
foreign government right we've argued
that we need to go into other countries
because we see instances of police
treating or military treating citizens
the way we have seen a lot of American
police treat protesters this week a very
very good point and well made thanks to
Walter for the sign-up Conrad Mattia
says do you know who Larry Lawton would
love to see you interview him he's the
next criminal who's working on prison
and police reform seems to share many of
your ideas check out his YouTube channel
he's great have heard of him not very
familiar with him Austin Shannon cielos
says David every video of Trump's walk
to st. John's Church has their audio
edited so you can't hear the tear gas
please look I can't be the only one that
notices the same interrupting static I
didn't notice that but I will check it
out Ron says what do you think of Tom
Cotton's piece in the New York Times in
the backlash I think the piece is
disgusting I think now the New York
Times is doing damage control trying to
you know they said oh this this actually
did not really meet our requirement or
editorial requirements etc etc and I you
know I know people that have canceled
their New York Times subscriptions
because they ran that Tom cotton screed
zesty African says I missed the man bun
shout out to keith Ellison for the great
work hope your stay
safe thank you Dutch Morgan says George
Floyd has been mourned more than Kobe
Bryant how it should be I watched some
of the some of the memorial service
today and it was it was excellent it was
excellent let me say thank you to
Thorsten bub let's Thorsten is new
supporter number two today now to be
perfectly frank
Thorsten made a patreon pledge but
that's everything counts tonight I don't
know how many of you are up to speed but
both so we we've dealt with YouTube and
Facebook the monetization in the past
I'm sorry we've dealt with YouTube D
monetization in the past the George
Floyd related content and police
brutality related content has been
widely demonetised on both YouTube and
Facebook I've said before I don't give a
[ __ ] we're gonna keep covering it we're
gonna keep talking about it but both
have overwhelmingly demonetized
all of that content so something like
half of the the stuff we did this week
was at least partially demonetised at
some point in time so my only message to
you is you can sort of like fight that
by grabbing a membership on my website
join pakman.com we do have a coupon code
use the coupon code
don't use the coupon code it's not
means-tested have a field day with the
coupon code if you want it'll save you
66% everybody who signs up I am going to
thank you profusely on this stream I see
names pop up on one of my 32 monitors
that I have here and I will thank you
profusely the website is working
beautifully we have I had a perfect
phone call earlier with our web
developer and she told me it is more
than ready to tolerate all of the
sign-up traffic that we are going to try
to throw at it so in any case I won't
say more about it now but join
pakman.com it's quick it's simple
grab a membership we estimate about half
of one percent of our audience has
memberships if we were able to double
that from 0.5 just to as Trump says it
if we could go from 0.5 to 1% we never
have to worry about any of this D
monetization nonsense again so something
to think about something to think about
ok
super chats continue to come in Browdy
Andrew Mulligan says tested positive for
kovat 19 antibodies I wanted to donate
plasma or plasma slash blood but cannot
because I'm gay thoughts on that band
could Corona help speed reform yeah III
believed that that had been dealt with
in some states but I may be wrong about
that and I don't want to misspeak but
I'm sorry to hear that Brody very sorry
to hear that
geek speek ten says Americans need to
get comfortable with being uncomfortable
or we never fix anything will this
moment spark it it may it certainly may
we don't know but I hope so
Kim way int sends a super chat Aquarius
70 and geek speek have grabbed YouTube
memberships which is very very exciting
over on Twitch I want to say thanks to
OB called EB called E says love the
stream need more subs appreciate that
deck Ned has subscribed and so has key
us 79 Adrian benningfield says David you
were saying become the good 1% exactly
oftentimes 1% is a pejorative term but
when it comes to supporting the David
Pakman show
if we can grow our support base from 0.5
percent of our audience to 1% of the
audience it will be an amazing an
amazing amazing 1% and on that note
Annie Bailey
Annie Bailey has just signed up at join
pakman.com Annie thank you you are a
good person I was going to say a great
American but I don't know that you're
American so I will just leave it at you
are a good person and that will be it so
very important announcement I will be
taking live calls on stream today we've
not done live calls for a little while I
will be doing them exclusively on Twitch
sorry I froze there had to be reset at
some point a little bit later
we are going to go exclusively over to
twitch for the stream twitch.tv/esa vyd
Pakman
and then I am going to blow the phone
lines wide open and hear from some of
you guys we've not done we've not done
live calls on a stream for a little bit
so that'll be very very exciting and of
course that will be once we get to 25
new members I mean listen this is not
you know it's not chopped liver my
friends okay other things that I wanted
to get to let's just see what's going on
I I don't want to miss what is going on
and so the great news is the protests
are just happening peacefully and you
know there's not really that much to say
other than what it turn out look at
what's going on here in the lower right
of the screen st. Louis Missouri
Missouri as some like to say a huge
crowd alongside what appears to be a
highway that's coverage from ass KSDK in
st. Louis bottom center is Atlanta
Georgia
it seems that so little is going on that
we're just following a guy who looks
like he's headed home from the gym he
looks like he has a gym bag with him
which is great it would be amazing if if
people were able to go to gyms we seem
to have sort of a recursive box in the
lower left where it is one of our boxes
is subsequently divided into twelve
further boxes and so it's it's recursive
coverage today New York City a lot of
action very peaceful Columbus Ohio San
Diego California still daylight there in
the upper right we have Seattle
Washington upper center is Austin Texas
and upper left is Washington DC a few
other specific streams that we've been
keeping an eye on this is another view
in metro Atlanta although it looks like
barely anything is going on I'm gonna go
over to 11alive and see if they have a
different stream oh I think this is the
the better stream nope this is a weather
stream which we definitely don't need
live protests let's take a look here
nope it just looks like police vehicles
so very very little going on in Atlanta
apparently this is Los Angeles and the
upper left and this large window
Minneapolis in the lower right in the
picture-in-picture and again a very very
peaceful protest that's going on let's
listen in just a little bit
oh this isn't even live this is
replay what are we even looking at
alright I'm closing that off and then
this is live in Washington DC you can
see the White House in the distance the
Washington Monument behind it and new
elements of fencing have been added in
Washington to say that Donald Trump is
scared I think would would be an
overstatement right now we don't know
that for sure but certainly they
continue to build fences in Washington
DC and that is it is what it is right it
is what it is other super chats coming
in let's see here JAAA Logan says I live
in Arkansas where neither district 1 or
senator has opponent how do you fix a
one-party state when the opposition
party doesn't even care that's a real
problem that's a major problem and you
know the Arkansas is very red so that
that may be causing abandonment issues
in terms of some of those some of those
races Matt Chavez's North Korea and Iran
are being critical of u.s. standards
that's sad I didn't see that but not
surprising stun ever says join Pakman
like me also find flippable seats in
Congress and donate to dem campaigns
around the country good advice Taleo
divino says hey David my grandparents
are devout trumpets and ignore any facts
I show them as being fake news is there
any way to get through to them I have a
bunch of YouTube clips about that you
know there are there are strategies it
part of it depends on like how much do
you want to potentially risk ruining the
relationship with your with your
grandparents and that would be a factor
in you know how what you decide to do
Adam fresh design sends a super chat
with no message and then says forgot my
message I live in South Bend and you
would not believe the amount of racist
comments I heard today at work I would
believe it I would believe it Walter
says I've seen this argument from
protest opposition that whites are more
likely to die to police than blacks
based on data if that is the case that
would mean they are okay with police
brutality if they are staying silent
we've actually done a deep dive into
violence against people by police and
looked at the racial numbers and it is
certainly
that the numbers are not as
disproportionate as some might imagine
but they are disproportionate and of
course my my ideology is facts and data
and you can check out that video on my
youtube channel and we might uh might
might be one to rehash or maybe update
given given the circumstances that we
are currently living through let me say
a few other thank-yous Christy McDonald
upgraded her subscription on my website
so we're counting her as number four
John Berry is number five at join
pakman.com Jacqueline Leigh so or lasso
is number six today Michael Kent is new
member number seven
Scott Ernest made a pledge at
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
we're going to count it and I very very
much appreciate that we will be opening
the phone lines today when we reach
twenty five members it will be happening
on an exclusive twitch stream and that's
going to be happening a little bit later
I do also want to thank some of the
people that are supporting over on
Twitch whose usernames are different
than those on YouTube nug Wrangler has
subscribed now for nine months in a row
is Mayo and instrument has subscribed
for two months with prime I consider
mayonnaise an instrument sure rot Kreutz
has subscribed for two months in a row
and sweet tooth has subscribed on twitch
and says hey David I'm a big fan of the
show you're by far my favorite gardening
channel on YouTube I love from Toronto
yeah very much appreciate that
tune in for politics from the left and
also amateur destructive gardening where
I am barely able to grow anything but I
have a great great time doing it which i
think is is half the fun is having fun
my friends half the pollen and politics
exactly I like them Taleo divino says
sorry I forgot to ask earlier do you
feel we need to worry about Trump being
able to convince the male military to go
along with him enough to hold on to the
presidency even if he
if he loses listen I may be wrong about
this we may be about to head down and
extremely an even darker path in this
country I believe Trump will leave under
protest but I don't think that the
military would assist Trump and staying
in the White House if he loses the Joe
Biden
I don't but no I just uh I I believe I
might be an idiot for believing it I
might be a naive [ __ ] but I believe
that despite how much our institutions
have been weakened I think Trump will
complain and say it was rigged if he
loses in November but I believe that he
will leave I believe that he ultimately
will leave thanks to Alec Stevenson for
upgrading your membership to alpha-alpha
on YouTube very very much appreciated
okay I had a couple of other things that
I wanted to show you guys let me just
find my list here and then I will pull
them up fullscreen where I should have
been better prepared on this oh here we
go okay so listen I'm not trying to do
disaster porn but I do want to just get
your thoughts as to like is is there any
possible justification for any of these
videos so here's a video where there's a
guy we're gonna look at this closely
this is New York City there's a guy
crossing the street on a bike wearing a
helmet and police start beating him with
batons and like he just seems to be
getting trying to get across the street
he's eventually knocked off of his bike
and he's clearly trying to avoid getting
hit is there any justification for what
we are seeing in this video or am i may
be being unfair like it is is there any
way this would be out of context for
what we are seeing is the warranted
behavior I just don't get it I don't I
don't see how that is remotely possible
I don't understand I you know I I don't
know some people are saying well there
was a curfew okay but the guys just
walking across the street with his bike
it is you know police are supposed to
give an opportunity for if people are
walking away or seem to be going home
you don't start beating them with
nightsticks that doesn't really make
sense I have another video this is so
there's something called medical
neutrality which is in any kind of
conflict situation civil unrest Wars
whatever you don't go after people
providing medical aid or first aid and
this is a medic who says that actually
let's just listen to what she says you
don't have to I don't have to summarize
we had set up a medical center elements
of medical so that anyone protesting
would be safe
we were not protesting we were not
agitating we had claimed that space this
is a set up a triage area in case of any
injuries we had I washed sutures EMTs
doctors EMS workers they came in in full
riot gear right hit us with shields
through several people to the ground
we were grabbed and thrown Sheldon
screamed at treated okay it's that so
the point is and I'm going to pause the
video where you actually see some of the
elements of medical here this I believe
is just bottled water that they've
essentially destroyed there's this thing
called medical neutrality where you
don't go after people that are providing
first aid if this were a geopolitical
war if this were two countries if one
country destroys the medical tent or you
know whatever it's considered a
violation of the Geneva Conventions and
what what appears to have happened is
that police destroyed this small medical
station that was going on there I I'm
again I'm trying to think like you know
steel Manning other other people and
charitable being charitable and all of
that stuff is there any way that you can
come up with even an imaginary situation
we're destroying the medical tent would
be justified when these are people
providing medical services these are you
know not doctors necessarily but medics
certainly I I can't think of anything
and I'm willing to look at what
people are are saying in the chat nobody
seems to be able to justify it so far
okay people are asking for me to show
some other videos but I don't know where
those videos necessarily are yeah anyway
I I can't think of any any justification
for what we are seeing there whatsoever
let me say thanks to Daniel Hooper
Daniel is new member number 9 today join
pakman.com really appreciate the support
Daniel thank you thank you thank you
thank you and feel free to use or not
use the coupon code 2020 now it I don't
we just want people to be involved at
whatever level is comfortable to them
take the coupon code by all means okay
other super chats that are coming in
Thoreau for backs says I'm a sporadic
supporter conflicted since I truly hate
your stance on vaping but now supporting
you regardless why it's my step what is
my stance on vaping that it's not
healthy even though some people claim it
is I mean is like obviously aerosolize
my stance on vaping is the following
here's a hot take for you there
the term vaping implies that we're
talking about water vapor which sounds
very innocuous what you're really doing
is aerosolizing chemicals and I don't
think there's any way that that's good
for your lungs so that's my position I
don't have any you know ideological
thing or just it when people say this is
maybe a healthy thing it's like how can
aerosolizing chemicals and putting them
into your lungs how could that be a
healthy thing anyway we must stand
united in defense of democracy don't let
youtube stifle you peaceful march on
washington 2.0 absolutely geek speek 10
says as a vet I agree the military won't
help him I think you mean the military
will not assist Donald Trump and staying
in the Oval Office if he loses like
Nabila says David you're a beta modified
soy boy Thanks is that is that a
compliment Batum modified soy boy thinks
oh oh that reminds me I have something
for you guys
that I think
I think it would it could it's it's too
risky let me tell you in a second anyway
I know giga chad is good giga chad is
good I don't know if beta modified soy
boy is good okay I'm gonna have
something for you guys in a second miles
Coffman says some Republican friends of
mine turned on Trump that's good
Maddie I Stevie D says David now is the
best time to start blowing trees does
that mean smoking pot I don't know what
that means
okay I let me tell you guys something
very very special there's this guy Jimmy
from Philly Jimmy from Philly is a very
very angry trumpet we haven't heard from
him for months at this point and he
would call in and we would mix it up and
some people like them some people didn't
like like him I never knew what Jimmy
from Philly looked like Jimmy from
Philly yesterday sent me four videos
that he uploaded to his Facebook page
and you see him every element of these
videos are like nothing that I have ever
seen before
and I think it has the potential to
[Music]
anything could happen if I were to play
these videos maybe those are videos that
I should be playing for you guys the
only concern I have is you know Jimmy
from Philly doesn't include his full
name and I don't want him doxed is the
thing if he doesn't want to be further
identified these are public videos that
he sent that's the only thing that I
kind of feel weird about let me just see
Jimmy from Philly
I would not that's the only thing you
know maybe let you know well here's what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna write back hey
Jimmy I would be interested in playing
these videos on stream I think the
audience would get a kick out of it but
I don't want to doxy you look at how
responsible I'm being can you guys
imagine I don't want to Doc's you are
you okay with
people potentially knowing your full
name and what you look like let me know
but this guy hates me and this is how I
look at how polite I am it's
unbelievable
okay I'm I'm realizing I shouldn't just
play it because you know I don't know if
the if these are really public on his
Facebook page or if you have to be
friends with actually wait I'm not
friends with him and I was able to see
it so I guess the point is I'm gonna ask
Jimmy if he were to get back to me Jimmy
if you're watching the stream somehow
get a message to me I might not see your
chat but people start somebody start
like trying to get my attention if Jimmy
is on any one of the streams okay very
very good that's somebody was pretending
to be Jimmy from Philly excellent so
that would be something maybe we could
look at very strongly at some point okay
Garrett Matheson Pooh Bear has signed up
Garrett Matheson says in Austin we're
medics were pelted with rubber bullets
for bringing in a seriously injured
protester called 911 to bring to police
Justin David says hi from Germany a
politician here with personal
connections to Harvard University said a
lot of people there unanimously claimed
there's little chance for trumps
reelection what do you think I don't
know that Harvard necessarily knows
everything about politics but it's it's
interesting oh wait a second is Jimmy in
the chat did Jimmy say that we can play
his videos no I guess not
some people are furious now that I
teased that and I'm not necessarily
going to play it okay I don't like guys
I can't tell if the real Jimmy is in the
chat and his okay me playing those
videos or not I'm gonna need something
else or maybe you know Jimmy respond to
my email let's do it that way respond if
you're in the chat respond to my email
and then I'll know that it is okay very
good
Dan samoflange hey David have you or
will you be protesting just curious no
snark Oh gotcha so I'm not planning to
join these protests between coronavirus
and the fact that my platform here
where I can amplify what's going on
nationally and you know remind everybody
that these protests are overwhelmingly
peaceful etc etc I think is much more
powerful than anything I can do holding
a sign and I don't want to potentially
spread the virus I don't want to
potentially catch the virus so no I
don't plan at this point in time I don't
plan to join the protest but I do plan
to continue supporting them via via the
show Robert Mifflin says VP ideas
Comella AG record won't go over well now
yeah I saw one report that says that
from from a merely mathematical
standpoint Kamala Harris is the quote
best choice for Biden given what's going
on right now and given her record at as
the California AG I am skeptical of
whether a Kamala Harris is the the best
person to be Joe Biden's VP but in two
months things could change and there's
probably some argument you could make I
would much rather see Elizabeth Warren
because I think she's the most
progressive of the people reasonably
being considered and that that's sort of
my thought at this point in time okay
guys we are going to go oh hold on a
thoreau for beck I'm a vaping activist I
didn't know what you you're trying to
get more people to vape I don't know
what that means thanks for addressing
the issue I'm sure you're acting in good
faith
down with the Trump Hunta viva la
revolucion okay very good
all right guys we are going to be taking
live phone calls we are going to be
taking live phone calls I am shortly
going to be blowing the phone lines wide
open but we are going to be doing it
only on Twitch so I will momentarily be
pinching off the YouTube stream the
Facebook stream and the Twitter stream
come participate over on Twitch we are
going exclusive at twitch.tv slash david
pakman twitch.tv slash david pakman
twitch.tv slash david pakman the stream
will not be interrupted over on Twitch
we are just going to stop the other
streams we are going only over to twitch
we will open the phone lines and you
guys will be allowed to call
in this could be risky we've not done
this for a little while this is a twitch
raid okay YouTube viewers raid twitch
Facebook raid twitch Twitter raid twitch
TV slash David Pakman okay we're gonna
stop the other streams now I will see
you on twitch momentarily and it's going
to be